year gordon attempted to turn around
restaurants all across america in a
moment you'll hear how some of them are
doing today but first a look back at
what finn mccool's was like when gordon
arrived a year ago
finn mccools is a family family-run
restaurant set in the heart of new
york's exclusive beach resort the
hamptons
it didn't take long for gordon to see
this irish pub had lost its way
[Music]
it's a grim buddy the patriarch
struggled to keep his business together
we're in trouble right now and his sons
were ready to tear each other apart you
don't listen anything i want to say you
almost want to tell them to shut up
while jason tended the bar
brian the chef was drunk with power in
the kitchen i'm not get out of here
melissa jason's wife was caught in the
middle brian jason butt heads a lot my
problems are more my brother
get out of here i would definitely not
recommend working with family
as soon as gordon stepped foot into finn
mccool's it was clear this family was in
major trouble so
what's the problem
[Music]
the family feud was taking a toll on
buddy and his business we just don't
have any money
everybody is in debt somewhere in the
hundreds of thousands
a retired cop he poured his life savings
into finn mccool's and watched it go
right down the drain
if there was no significant improvement
how long could you afford to stay open
for we're in trouble right now you know
we're probably i would say 5 000 a week
under what we need to survive so 20
grand a month i haven't taken a check
yet and you can't catch them
no
we need this for our families right more
in every night going to bed you can be
able to pay this mortgage i can't
describe to you how stressful that is
the debt and family fighting were
dragging finn mccools down and the food
unfortunately only made matters worse
here you are spring rolls with coleman's
mustard wow
are they poppy on the menu um people
really like them
no doubt half the customers are drunk
then the one dish an irish pub should be
known for shepherd's pie sent gordon
over the edge it's just a big ball of
grease
that's disgusting
which one second door left
oh no
oh my god
having barely recovered from the
shepherd's pie gordon decided it was
time chef brian heard the painful truth
when a chef can't make a [ __ ]
shepherd's pie it worries me
was that you at your best
whatever he has to tell me i don't
really care
[Music]
to observe the staff of finn mccool's
inaction gordon invited the local fire
department
but the brigade was less than impressed
is there something wrong
back in the kitchen gordon was not happy
with the amount of frozen food being
used when was the last time we got fresh
vegetables in the house
last summer
now i just cringe when i see them that's
all
and one shocking shortcut left gordon in
disbelief
francis
he took off the floor put in the fryer
and then back in the sauce
i've never ever ever seen anything quite
extraordinary as that
yeah well the fryer is going to uh
it's going to
take anything to come off the floor
and that cleans it
[Music]
sterilize it sterilize it
[ __ ] me
that night buddy the owner and brian the
chef nearly came to blows i'm not
kidding i said all right over how brian
was running the kitchen
i'm [ __ ] saying it right here i'm
doing what i got to do watch him out
watch your mouth get out of here
i didn't even want to be here anymore i
don't know if i wanted to be in the
kitchen anymore never mind here
you know out of here i'm done working
here brian reached his boiling point
leaving finn mccools without a chef
if he wasn't my son i'd have fired his
ass out of here with nowhere else to
turn buddy
and jason
coming for them
but [ __ ] say we're left running the
kitchen and not doing a very good job
buddy buddy buddy
with their chef gone for the first time
buddy and jason realized the stress
brian was under you get a renewed
respect for what brian has to go through
it's tough job all these times that i'm
hard on my brother and we fight about
stuff and i couldn't do what he does i
wonder brian's a cranky [ __ ]
[Music]
the next day gordon gained valuable
insight into the pressures brian faced
there's parts of me that
feel for you in a way that i
i started to understand what's on your
shoulders
have you thought about quitting and
setting up elsewhere
[Music]
counseling yeah
you've got to handle it a different way
in a way that you become
the responsible one
okay thank you good man
chef ramsay definitely kicked me in the
ass and got me excited to do what i'm
doing
[Music]
the following day gordon implemented
some essential changes beginning with a
fresh new look welcome
to finla calls yes
lovely
wow is that beautiful that is gorgeous
huh
oh my gosh you walked in and you felt
like you were in your home it was it was
so comfortable holy moses
wow i'm in shock
it was very cool seeing that just look
on his face when we walked in there wow
i'm happy
but gordon's key change not surprisingly
was the menu
the first thing i did was got rid of two
thirds of the menu because it wasn't
fresh what's the point having on there
gordon even taught brian his own family
recipe for shepherd's pie i'm straight
off that fact to think that we are
fortunate enough to be schooled by a man
like chef ramsay well you'd be a fool
not to uh not to jump on this
news of the relaunch spread throughout
the hamptons and finn mccool's was
packed
this is their one big last chance at
getting this thing right we opened up
the floodgates
although it was their busiest night ever
i've seen you work well
the mazzio family came together and
proved they had what it takes to run a
restaurant
at least for one night
gordon ramsay you know made me feel like
uh i wanted to cook again there was a
buzz everybody felt it you know and we
were a family again we appreciate what
he did all the work that he did didn't
fall on deaf ears i was proud
really proud
[Music]
a year has gone by now let's see how
finn mccall's is doing today
i arrived at calls over a year ago to a
family an absolute turmoil i'm dying to
find out what's going on are they still
arguing are they still fighting has
buddy cashed his checks come on
when chef ramsay arrived hey look at you
i thought he was gonna be happy and i
was glad that he could see that his
words and his advice didn't fall on deaf
ears melissa yeah nice to see you
likewise when gordon ramsay first came
in i was actually excited because i knew
he was going to be proud of us good to
see you so i didn't feel nervous like i
did last time where's the arrogant
[ __ ] where is he
where is he hey bride
chef ramsay you hear his voice it's just
like you go uh-oh hi my man all right
good to see you good to see you too
likewise i want him to see that i listen
to what he told me and hopefully make
somebody like of his stature proud of me
am i glad to be back here you know that
ah i hope so last time i saw you i
looked at a chef that was pissed off and
didn't want to be here all right yeah
i'm out of here i'm done working here
[Music]
are you busting these balls
yes chef no yes sir
uh yeah he's still an arrogant bastard
but he's my arrogant bastard and i love
him business how's it been the last 12
months we are up average across the
board
35
great are you cashing your checks
million dollar question hey cheers
everybody
when i first arrived losing 20 grand a
month yeah there's no losses per month
no are you making money yeah we're at a
point right now where i don't know we're
dying it's nice to go home and know that
you can pay your bills and wake up in
the morning and go to work and you're
gonna make some more money it's a pretty
good feeling we are just
heads and tails above where we were and
i owe that to chef ramsay have you been
yeah i had a little glitch there for a
little bit what happened i had a heart
attack he was yeah yeah
my dad's heart attack was it was a
very
traumatizing experience for a lot of
different ways and it was bad you know
the doctor told him he could have he
could have died that was a very scary
time who's getting the prime rib
realizing how close we were to losing
him it was beyond scary i was down for
a few weeks actually
and i was shocked the three of them
stepped up took the bull by the horns
and when i came back everything was
perfect
i don't think last year we could have
done it if this would have happened
before ramsay came i think that finn
mccool's would have been doors locked
done bloody good to see you now yeah
honestly
it really is that [ __ ] handshake i
swear to god honestly i feel like you
crushed my fingers
it takes three days for the blood to go
back
since chef ramsay was here we learned a
lot of really valuable lessons when we
all work together to run smooth i'm so
happy to see my son enjoy what he's
doing because brian's passion for
cooking has come back and it's stronger
than ever i feel a lot better uh-huh you
get good feedback which makes you want
to go to work the next day after chef
ramsay left brian was a changed person
you know just a new man walked into the
kitchen and the food that he's putting
out is not only is it beautiful it
tastes wonderful we have people coming
from all over and they're blown away by
how good the food is last time there was
so much frozen food here i got upset
with you yes
when was the last time we got fresh
vegetables in the house
how much is your produce is fresh now
all of it all of this show me your
freeze please yeah chef ramsay
definitely set the bar high as far as
standard wise but you know how do you
not listen to what chef ramsay tells you
to do fresh meat fresh meat fresh
vegetables that was chef ramsay's thing
you know he was like you're an island
you know we're long island monkfish
calamari so it was crazy not to have
fresh seafood
that's the marinade for the chicken so
the world famous chicken wings yes
delicious does francis still come in and
pick them off the floor
he's moved on to us he's gone yes yes uh
right what's the special today um well
tonight we're uh a nice fried local
calamari we're doing a little uh roasted
pepper remy live with that lovely
shepherd's pie as a matter of fact we're
trying to figure out a way to market
because i'm getting phone calls from st
louis or something from state lewis st
louis for chef it's pie yeah yeah it's
great yeah i change it depending on
seasonally what kind of vegetables we're
going with spring rolls over here
yes oh [ __ ]
by popular demand we did have to put the
spring rolls back on the menus spring
rolls what we've done with them last
time we're using carvings from the from
the roast beef throw it in [ __ ] bits
right now now they're fresh the cabbage
is steamed directly for that you sound
proud of them they're nice and the
people love them i'd like to taste them
again if you've reinvented it
wonderfully you sound so confident brian
you know that we're having fun it's
refreshing it's great yes my brother's
attitude's changed completely it really
has i mean he's a chef and chefs are
crazy they'll always be crazy but his
attitude's so much more positive it
makes the whole family dynamic a lot
easier
here we go chef thank you my dog food
chowder lovely thank you
and our famous sprinkles
i think they're good but not only do i
think they're good customers love them
it's kind of our signature thing
they are nice
that
is delicious thank you for somebody that
statue to come in and compliment you on
things it's amazing tasty yeah
absolutely tasty we stuck with what he
showed us how to do we're reaping the
benefits because we did he made us who
we are right now we did everything he
said
and he was spot on what he's done here
has uh it's had a lasting effect and it
will it's it's uh
he's helped us go in a positive
direction this
is a thousand miles away from what i
tasted last time
more importantly over that you guys look
happy
spring rolls kind of the recipe no
[Music]
the thin recalls family restaurant yes
and more importantly
buddy's health
yes good health best wishes thanks
brian
[Music]
i know
it's my boy
that is one very happy family and it's
so nice to see because they're back in
love they're busy and they're making
money game over
last year when gordon rode into tuckahoe
new york a wealthy commuter town outside
of manhattan
he was at first intrigued by the old
stone mill
beautiful
what a beautiful building what scares me
is why no one's eating here i'm about to
find out
business at this upscale restaurant had
ground to a halt there was dean the
cocky owner i don't believe there's a
better operator or restaurateur than me
who was desperate to succeed you need
the [ __ ] tickets while mike the chef
had lost hope
do i still have passion for food
no
barbara dean's wife was a nervous wreck
this restaurant isn't just a restaurant
it's our life it's our future it's our
children's future
[Music]
six years ago dean bought this 200 year
old mill with the dream of turning it
into a restaurant i have a recurring
nightmare that i've had from day one
what happens if i open up staffed up
food ready and no one decides to come
here well it happened
this year
gordon
how are you i'm mean
nice
the guy's a winner his michelin stars
are like world series rings he's got
them but it didn't take long for dean to
change his tune about gordon look at
that
what's that squashed into
okay that's it there
right that sits on top was the chef a
mechanic
you know this is my house he was in my
house and he was
embarrassing me
[Music]
okay and it only got worse when gordon
tried one of the specialties of the
house
it's gross
looking it looked like it came out of a
baby's diaper
honestly
your food's crap
i was pissed i wanted to take the plate
and smash it on top of the chef's head
[Music]
after being wounded by gordon's
criticism of the food there was more
pain when gordon delved into the
restaurant's finances
are you aware of the current financial
situation brother
um he kind of keeps me in the dark a
little bit i don't want her to worry
if we
had to close yeah tonight
will be
oh
half a million
half a million yeah
got money tied up in the
home
mortgage-wise oh sure
i just choose not to deal with it right
now i'll let him do it if the house gets
taken away you lose that then every
reason to be worried
a financial crisis and bad food weren't
the only problems plaguing this
restaurant
on weekends when the restaurant was busy
dean tended to overstay his welcome at
the tables just okay
just okay and in the kitchen he seemed
more concerned about the speed of the
cooking i need a result on a tilapia
that's done then the quality got me very
frustrated we let the customer wait if
he waits 20 minutes and he's happy or he
waits 20 minutes gets crap what's worse
does it make you feel better if we rush
this to the table
no i'm amazed you know more than
anything
i don't know i don't know what you i
don't know what you want me to say to
you your restaurant is on the ass
after a disappointing dinner service
gordon confronted dean over his lack of
commitment to make real changes i think
you're treating this like a game how
dare you accuse me of not having a
commitment hey you i don't have a day
i'm telling you you're not telling me
anything this is your own figment of
your imagination that i don't have a
commitment to this place you just give
me two minutes you guys do you mind
you float on the customers coming around
blowing smoke up your ass that's right i
do when i ask people how their food is
they tell me it's good it makes me feel
good i don't wobble around my customers
kissing how was it please tell me don't
go to the table yes people had a
mealwords or no you probably paid 10
people to go to the table i listen to
the phone every morning fully booked i
have this is what i get free to do to
stand in here that's what i get paid to
do to sit here next to people and give
them a good [ __ ] experience that's
what i get paid what does [ __ ] come out
no
that doesn't feel good about it no i
don't feel good there you go again
that's my opinion what about it you
[ __ ] did it's what i gotta do that's
what i do you're a fake [ __ ] you you're
a fake
you're a [ __ ] fake
[Music]
is how you gonna act walk away you're
not face it like a [ __ ] man
the next morning undeterred by dean
gordon canvassed the town to see how the
old stone mill could carve a niche in
the neighborhood this place has got
every chance of becoming a phenomenal
steakhouse
dean still reluctant to change was not
convinced
i'm fuming that was your resurrection of
the place i i've got 12 successful
russians highly profitable and you my
man missed out on a [ __ ] trick you've
got some serious thinking to do
before gordon could convert the old
stone mill into a steakhouse he knew he
had to work with chef mike to get his
passion back
first big change prime rib frame rib
gordon's idea of a steakhouse would
really work here he's 100 right that
there is nothing else in the area gordon
added a number of exciting meat dishes
and said goodbye to some old stone milk
classics like the funnel salad meltdown
okay
yes
oh just think of the complaints what
you're not stopping my salad in a funnel
after re-energizing mike gordon knew he
would have to get through to dean if
there was any hope of saving the old
stone mill
the fascinating thing about you dean is
that you're
you're scared of failure
walk a mile in my shoes and then we'll
talk i failed before in business
when when i opened a restaurant in my
hometown thinking i was the dog's
bollocks and it made me the person i am
today don't be scared you can't keep on
sidestepping problems
you're right i gotta implement changes
to make this work this time i can't wait
any longer
now confident that dean was ready to
accept change gordon unveiled his plan
beginning with some aesthetic changes
outside
look at it beautiful and in
oh my goodness
it's open it's classic barbara what do
you think
really the dark colors too depressing
yes i'm man enough to admit that it's
great
minutes after the doors opened for the
relaunch the steakhouse was jammed with
eager customers including the mayor the
kobe beach
but an hour into this important service
the kitchen printer broke down and chef
mike and his staff were totally confused
i need the mayor's table man i'm not
getting tickets to this printer right
now please help me i don't remind medium
rare ticket is when i'm sorry [ __ ] if
this is the copy you gotta have the
other hand this comes from the salad
quarter it's been an hour and i got
nothing
read the [ __ ] kick it oh [ __ ] out
here we go what the [ __ ]
it's the last [ __ ] table
[Music]
before the dinner service spun
completely out of control mike just come
around for two seconds please yes gordon
got the stamp focused again
let's get this thing back online
especially this critical moment this is
going to make or break this place i will
be right back and i will wrap those up
for you thank you medium rare
everyone rallied and the night finished
on a high note sorry get mistaken
[Music]
well bon appetit i certainly hope it was
worth the wait
excellent
by the end of the evening it was clear
gordon's vision for the old stone mill
was a success the most important thing
is the confirmation that it can work the
potential is staggering now that you
know what to do don't stop doing it
thank you gordon ramsay he's such a
blessing to our family that we could
never
ever thank him enough for all that he's
done for us i think he got something
[ __ ] phenomenal
now i have something to really be proud
of
thanks
thank you
good luck thanks man i'm excited about
what the future holds here
a year has gone by now let's see if dean
stuck to gordon's plan and turned his
steakhouse around
when i first arrived at the old stone
mill i fell in love with the building it
is beautiful what i didn't fall in love
with was the food so we changed the
direction of the restaurant and its
owner dean time to find out what's going
on
well well look at you look at you
immaculate as ever how are you i
thought you forgot about me i have very
mixed emotions about gordon coming back
here and i don't know whether i want to
hug him or punch him what is this botox
or is it just you ah i'm just asking you
to stop with that
look at you
like a male model for god's sake
huh family all well everyone's great
yeah it's been real good how's business
been initially yep double that's
fantastic and then some um
literally last week that's last week
what was the food like she loved it
that's fantastic yeah man
where are we uh year on this winter i am
up 25 to 30
last year at this point i was falling in
the red severely
and this year i'm not on maintaining
people are paid the staff is paid my
mortgage is paid and that's a good thing
who's in the kitchen mike yeah
where is it right there
no it's freezing
no
the funnel before oh come on
touching a tender cord with the funnel
issue with me you know
just for you and you owe me four dollars
you burned my last two
oh just think of the complaints what
you're not stopping my salad in a funnel
hey where did that come from the car oh
it's the fill the salt and pepper
we use a different man today
i could kind of get like this guy last
time i saw you down here you look like a
man that was hurting now you look a
completely different guy
it's been a lot less stressful so the
weight's gone the answer reflux is gone
it's all good my own patch of cooking
has changed it's when when you want to
come to work and you're excited to come
to work at shows
which wasn't there i'd say a year ago
before chef got here the first time
happy with the steakhouse yes yes and
friday saturday night how many colors
what you're doing i'd say anywhere from
120 150. well overall business is better
people need to call for reservations
there is a wait on on weekend nights the
numbers are up so that numbers don't lie
yeah can i just say seriously you look
great thank you relax and not the kind
of sort of worried individual i saw last
time you know i was a mess
you need to [ __ ] kick it oh [ __ ]
out here we go
[Applause]
but i tell you what i don't put out
fires anymore i i'm growing the place
instead of worrying about sustaining it
you were heavily in debt last time i saw
you correct what's the situation now
this spring i will certainly chip away
but i caught up and i'm current
hey
here's the glamour how are you
very good
[Music]
thank you i was most proud to show him
my wife being comfortable and at ease
and happy and not crying
he looks a different man i mean not just
he's using bravado with confidence but
relax and so nice to see you stress-free
yeah
yeah it's a light relief right oh it's
such a relief
it's it's a relief just to wake up and
see a smiling face instead of seeing
somebody stressed out it's always stress
but it's good stress now that's a happy
problem being busy it's a privileged
dilemma yeah and you were that close i
was i was screwing yourselves on the
restaurant it was almost gone so it was
heartbreaking for me right and then
you're such a stubborn [ __ ] to get
through to you don't like the truth dean
no i don't like the truth no one's
birthday [ __ ] i heard the truth of my
life more than you'll ever hear the
truth oh [ __ ] yeah that's what you think
sure it's like twice somebody's like
banging my head against the old stone
mill because you weren't for it to begin
with
you mentioned steakhouse and it was the
penny didn't drop straight away well you
know why because because you were scared
of change weren't you you were sort of
scared within you yeah yeah i didn't
want to fail you know i wanted i didn't
want to lose what i had and i couldn't
afford to you know when you can't pay
your bills and you're not thinking
clearly you make stupid choices yeah i
made some stupid decisions yeah it
wasn't the changes he made to the old
stone mill it was the changes that he
made to me
gordon gave me a swift kick in my
you-know-what i'm happy you're both
happy
i needed you in here i was lucky enough
and blessed to get you in here i
weathered the storm it's behind me and i
guess i can give gordon credit for that
as much as i hate to
i'd like to introduce somebody very
special genotul from the new york beef
industry council to present a very
special award
we like to say congratulations on your
incredible turnaround and continued
success well thank you very much thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
congratulations to get an award from the
new york beef industry council is
special and something i'll never forget
but to get it from him there's even more
absolutely
yes thank you so much the core of what
he gave us is certainly there and i
stayed true to the concept and to him
like he said it won't happen overnight
but stay the course and and it'll pay
off and and his words were never so true
it certainly paid off
[Music]
located just outside of new york city in
belmore the mixing bowl was a thriving
restaurant 10 years ago but in the last
few years business had dwindled to
almost nothing i'm nervous because this
looks dreadful
[Music]
billy the owner and chef was barely
holding on i'm so stubborn about keeping
it alive but am i hurting myself am i
hurting my family mike the manager was
losing it i wasn't told why you keep
saying that i'm pissed off lisa billy's
wife wanted to close the doors i can't
sacrifice myself and our children
for the mixing bowl anymore
this once popular restaurant was on its
last legs
and when it came to the food gordon had
little if anything nice to say about
billy's cooking
zucchini pancakes like having a mouthful
of glue
it didn't blow me away today and it's
very sad
end of story
gordon noticed immediately that billy
operated more like a line cook never
leaving the kitchen do you ever go out
there
yeah when i
you know it dies down i'll walk around
allowing manager mike to run the
business into the ground
i'm taking fifty percent off my check
fifteen fifty no no five oh fifty
holy smoke
but mike's ridiculous coupons paled in
comparison to his promotional signs
all of them go in the window at some
point
where did you get all these from i have
a place they make them up for me it was
expensive is there anything else that i
should know
that's it
that is it
well there's about well
oh no
gordon can you come here it's a little
big
what in the [ __ ]
free appetizer with dinner oh [ __ ] um
get me out of here
[Music]
gordon knew it was time to have a heart
to heart with billy and lisa i've got to
be [ __ ] brutally honest with you you
know that you seriously have to start
thinking as a businessman and then
watching you cooking you look like a man
that's dying to be put out of his misery
lisa you may be right maybe we should
close this place down [ __ ]
tonight if the restaurant dies it'll be
like a death in the family
and turn this around
[Music]
seriously no
unless you change you'll be gone in six
weeks time
the next day gordon was on a mission to
turn the mixing bowl around
it's time to say goodbye to the past
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
later that morning gordon revealed his
plan to help the mixing bowl make its
mark in this competitive neighborhood
healthy is something that's not even
lifted anywhere near here
taking advantage of a need in the area
for healthy dishes gordon and billy went
to work in the kitchen creating new
specials for the next dinner service
this is the kind of food that the mixing
bowl should be serving this is a poached
salmon topped with a walnut pesto
it's exciting to realize you can do
things healthy and just open my eyes to
a whole new world
yeah okay okay this is something special
yeah if you like salmon yeah i would try
salmon the success of the new salmon
dishes with customers validated the new
direction of the mixing bowl
good
but the front of the house was still
suffering from mike's managerial style
is he working out all he does is stand
and talk and lean and pray
give me you gotta work the tips baby
it's impossible to work with him and he
takes half of your tips you get five
times more paid than the servers what
the hell is your problem and in a
post-dinner meeting the staffs and
billy's wife lisa's frustration with
mike reached a breaking point when i'm
busting my own tables and everybody else
is running around crazy we are aware of
what the problems were
i'm fighting for my life here
you right now need to step up to the
plate and make the changes every
freaking day every minute of the day
that's it
billy
that's the first time
you sounded like a boss
because it's your [ __ ] life on the
line don't ever forget that
with everyone now on the same page about
the plan moving forward gordon's team
gave the mixing bowl decor a facelift
wow it's gorgeous
it looks like a restaurant now doesn't
it yes are you serious you're gonna
start spending time in your own
restaurant now you're saying hello to
customers yep
it's gorgeous lisa if you want any
tissues
hey
[Music]
and to complement the decor gordon
designed a menu rich in healthy
ingredients
good luck
yes
let's go big boy
it was time for the relaunch
but minutes after opening it was clear
that mike had overbooked the restaurant
it looks like we have 47. well no
and on top of that there was a mix-up
with the reservation for the new york
dragons football team you're overlooking
extremely important things
i was not told about the dragons i found
out like why you keep saying that
because i wasn't i wasn't told
that's it
not my fault
you would please move on that day hey
yes you [ __ ] off outside now
let me just tell you something
you've got one problem here
mike
mike's gonna have to change like the
place has changed it's everybody else
and the place is gonna be a second
chance so am i shooting a second chance
after mike's blow up everything settled
down and the relaunch was a success all
right table two's getting up we're gonna
push it together for a table of four
it's so different it feels great
everybody's really loving the food
we are going to build the best damn
restaurant
that
that
ever existed and at the end of the night
billy finally came out of his kitchen
i'm so proud of him i couldn't be more
proud of her
the difference tonight from when i first
arrived was extraordinary
your talent is big boy
you've got to make that transition from
a chef to russian tour
ladies
i got the message on how i have to
change to make this place the best it
could be good night thank you thank you
last year when gordon arrived at the
mixing bowl he found an empty restaurant
that was about to go bust oh this is
quiet
mike the manager was spinning out of
control can we please move on that's it
while billy the owner was stuck in the
kitchen you're holding everything up now
with all this crap and billy's wife lisa
had simply given up my hope is really
gone for this place
but by the time gordon left all three
were re-energized and determined to
succeed i'm so proud of him i couldn't
be more proud about it now it's time to
find out how they're doing today
when a person over the mixing bowl
everybody was stressed the hell mike the
manager was running around like a
[ __ ] headless chicken lisa the chef's
wife well she wanted to close the place
and billy the chef he was just chained
to the stove now when i left things were
much better i hope they're still like
that let's go
well there's no signs and there's
customers
what are you doing here out ah i'm on
the phone hi
are you good to see him emmanuel
ah
nice big smile on your face
the last year since uh chef ramsay's
been here it's been amazing business has
improved
three four times what it was it's been
unbelievable that's looking nice
nice to see you are you well good to see
that good to see you my man ah how's
things things have been great we made
top 20 best restaurants in long island
for 2007. that's great news i think it
makes him proud to see that you know he
gave us the tools he did all this for us
well done are you happy oh yes very good
yeah and feedback from the customers
great feedback people love the food
prior to chef ramsay coming here i never
thought that the restaurant could change
the way that it did we turn away 50 100
people a night now for dinner we need a
300 seat restaurant
coupons
no no no we don't need coupons there's
got to be one no
no
i'm taking 50 percent off
15. 15. no no 5.0 50.
the biggest lesson that i learned from
gordon ramsay was that people should
want to come to your restaurant you
shouldn't have to
bribe them nice to see the windows so
clear no signs
great you must have thought about
something along the way a little sign a
picture of us out there that's about it
[ __ ] of who all of us you and i
together oh yeah i haven't seen that
oh my god it is
people drive by like wow gordon ramsay
you know remember the last time we were
out here you'll show me all your signs
holy mackerel i tried everything
the customers they're the ones that are
spreading the word so
we don't need any signs or any
promotions or any gimmicks anymore i did
not expect to see you in the dining room
yeah are you spending time between
kitchen and dining room yeah perfect
half and half that's great getting to
meet customers yeah that's fantastic how
you doing tonight i think the most
important thing chef ramsey did to help
out the restaurant was
i think in me how are we doing on table
five and bringing me out into the
restaurant and start running the whole
restaurant instead of half of it
hey
look at you another smiley face how are
you doing good to see you my darling oh
the past year has been unbelievable
since chef ramsay came we going to catch
up five minutes somewhere everything's
different at the mixing bowl last time
we sat in this office i wanted it yeah
close the place did how do you know
lisa you may be right to put you out
your misery maybe we should close this
place down tonight
[Music]
to see him now standing in there i mean
he's a different guy he's transformed so
different yeah different when he comes
home different one is here brilliant no
regrets no no no regrets do you still
want to kill or strangle mike you know i
don't he's really turns around no i just
need that food okay i'll take the cake
you got it mike is completely different
now and when was last time you flipped
town when the dragons came in
[Music]
he's really been
much calmer he's being much calmer oh
everyone's just so much happier and i
think everyone's a lot more at ease now
mike's not yelling i'm not yelling no
one's yelling it's very nice
are you happy that you didn't sell the
restaurants i am i am at this point i
really am yeah thankfully everything's
yeah going great yeah yeah i mean you've
transformed i mean you've just you've
got this glow on you i don't know where
you got it from but completely
he's so much easier to be around yeah i
mean i talk now yeah right no it's true
it's true
it's been quite a ride it's changed my
life
100 it's been unbelievable this is his
life
cooking
being a chef having a restaurant he
loves it
i'm really proud yeah really proud and
very happy that it's going so well don't
stop
please
and as a way of saying well done
this is for billy
that is for you thank you you deserve it
[Music]
[Applause]
yes the mixing bowl is awarded gordon
ramsay's seal of approval for excellence
and consistency
quality and overall customer
satisfaction
it's like a thousand pounds lifted
because i'll never forget where i was a
lot of businesses don't always get a
second chance so i don't take anything
for granted hey
this is the longest we've ever spent
together without any tears
ah come here
yes hey
well done and that yeah i really mean
don't stop
take care thank you bye guys
bye-bye
it's so hard to believe that this place
nearly closed they're happy they're
making money and they're doing a [ __ ]
good job success is the only sign they
need
manhattan may be the mecca for great
restaurants but last year in the heart
of the big apple gordon found his
biggest challenge ever there's one
restaurant that needs my help more than
any other and it's right down there
dylan's an indian restaurant in midtown
was a catastrophe
the menu was confusing where are we
choosing from which menu the food was
appalling it was disgusting and the
kitchen was infested
the kitchen's not clean
martin the general manager didn't seem
to care
andrew the operations manager struggled
to keep everything running something's
broken i fix it i make sure that there's
toilet paper to wipe your butt with
while mohamed the owner was losing a
fortune for last six months we are
losing like 20 to 30 thousand dollars a
month this indian eatery was a disaster
martin general manager this is dylan's
women's
indian restaurant indian restaurant yes
it doesn't sound like an indian does it
it didn't take long for gordon to
realize he was facing a huge challenge
first off the menu wasn't even indian
british italian buffalo yes the only
thing that's not on here is chinese
secondly and more importantly the dishes
were barely edible there's two fritters
they're both visible yes
there's meat in there
and that one's got meat in there
it's not vegetarian it tastes like blam
you guys are
killing me right now the sordid
vegetarian appetizer plate has to be
vegetarian vegetarian he just had a meat
one
after having a vegetarian appetizer that
wasn't even vegetarian
gordon dug into his next dish beef buna
that is not a piece of beef
does that look like a piece of beef to
you my darling it looks like pork if
that's beef then hey
i was born in bangladesh
he says it's pork pretty sure it's pork
the beef
pretty much everything that could go
wrong went horribly and catastrophically
wrong where did you start on this one
gordon knew there was an awful lot to do
in a short amount of time welcome but
before he could start he had to observe
dylan's inaction are we going to reset
this table eeny meeny
manager by the toe you are what
you're the floor manager
holy mackerel
okay farooq oh [ __ ] holy moses hello
floor manager operations manager general
manager anybody
mammoth
can you explain to gomez yes yeah that
we've got to stop putting things on the
floor
it's unhygienic i'm hygienic
not surprisingly chaos in the kitchen
resulted in poorly prepared food
and unhappy customers in two minutes
we're leaving and you know we asked like
seriously two minutes
but the next day gordon uncovered
dylan's biggest horror lurking in the
basement
what's that smell
what
is that for rats or mine
it's rat droppings look at them all
oh my good god
oh my god look i've got one in my
[ __ ] hair it's cockroaches boxes full
of them
look
look at them all
oh
no
look at that
shocked by the deplorable conditions
gordon called for the management to meet
him in the kitchen
are you in charge of this are you
responsible for this
uh gentleman it gets worse than that
it's green
it's beyond edible
look
at the color of those chicken wings
everything in there was putrid how long
has that been in there
give me an answer because i'm [ __ ]
myself yes uh there's a head chef
responsible for this
kill somebody
we're not passing the bug but i know my
general manager knows what the [ __ ]
going on in my fridges let me just tell
you something i've eaten here
the kitchen is closed
right now out there and telling the
truth gordon was so
outraged so
angry from green burgers to the [ __ ]
berry cucumber
hello hi
i'm sorry to inform you that we are not
going to be serving dinner this evening
chef ramsay's shut down the kitchen
would we need a death in the restaurant
before some [ __ ] gets agreed
undeterred by the disgusting conditions
gordon returned to the restaurant
equipped to deal with the mess
[Music]
with the help of professional steam
cleaners
guys get you straight through there
gordon and the staff of dylan's worked
through the night getting rid of all the
old rotten food and sterilizing every
square inch of the restaurant
in the days that followed gordon's
design team dramatically changed the
decor
[Music]
dylan's drab and dreary look take off
your blindfolds was transformed into a
sleek contemporary indian restaurant
haven't they done an amazing job this is
beautiful outside gordon installed an
eye-catching awning revealing the
restaurant's new authentic indian name
purnima
but the most critical change was
gordon's decision to enlist one of new
york's top indian chefs vikas khanna to
help make over the menu after the trio
we have the chicken korma the new menu
featured classic indian dishes with a
modern twist
[Music]
hello good evening on the night of the
relaunch with vikas in charge the
kitchen got off to a great start
let's go
but unfortunately poor management
created chaos in the dining room
so they want the lamb
the ladies that yeah
the disorganization in the dining room
created confusion in the kitchen who's
running the restaurant and customers
were forced to suffer the consequences
fed up with the dismal service gordon
asked floor manager khan to step up be
honest with me
can you manage this place yes i can
ready to go ready everything is ready
with vikkas manning the kitchen the
staff hit its stride
and the opening was a smashing success
[Music]
feeling that there was now hope for this
restaurant
gordon sat down with muhammad for a
candid conversation about martin this is
a new start
you have to treat it as a new beginning
of course in a perfect world i would
sacrifice one of your managers to employ
vegas
between you and i martin's not worth his
weight in terms of what he brings to the
table hearing gordon ramsay say that to
muhammad that makes me upset and angry
i've never used you i've i've respected
you i'm proud of what we've done i've
never cheated you like
what's going on i'm recommending you
reckon winning you are enough i've had
enough thank
so
let him go go on this person i've
expected you knew that the audacity to
accuse me of like taking his mind off
his back
is
what you said well that is disgusting
you have no right i have nothing to be
guilty of
you what nothing you ran it you sat in
there yes you wasted it yes i wasted you
encouraged it
this wasn't always
[Music]
i think gordon ramsay is full of [ __ ]
and i'm extremely angry extremely pissed
off and i now turn my back and walk away
determined to move forward muhammad
asked vikas to come on board as a
consultant thanks a lot appreciate it
thank you thank you let's be honest it's
gone exceptionally well great food great
decor great buzz happy customers thank
you
for all of us over here i thank you very
very much thank you
a year ago gordon faced his toughest
assignment right in the middle of
manhattan at an indian restaurant
plagued with bad food it's rotten
inefficient managers who's running the
restaurant and one of the dirtiest
kitchens gordon had ever seen rat
droppings oh my god
with the help of chef vikas gordon left
the restaurant in a good state
let's be honest it's not exceptionally
well
but a year has gone by and one wonders
if the manhattan mess is even open time
to find out
last year dylan's was my biggest
nightmare of all time personally i could
hardly step foot in the place it was
badly run and festered with cockroaches
so i'm dying to find out how they're
doing let's go
there you are how you doing i'm doing
well thank you good to see you welcome
back can i just say first of all it
smells nice in here it's going to be
very interesting to see how gordon
reacts today oh you i've i've been well
thank you i hope that he's going to
enjoy what he sees because we're proud
of what we're doing now as opposed to
slightly embarrassed in terms of
business um are we up yes that's great
news yeah have you been i've been very
well actually i've had the great
pleasure of working with vegas hannah
and it's been a tremendous experience
vikas is still here yes that's great yes
good good good chicas is is sort of
become the anchor the leader the
visionary the greatest thing that
happened from gordon coming here was him
bringing vegas cilantro vinaigrette
worked extremely well because has the
ability to inspire people and we are now
committed to being an indian restaurant
in the best indian restaurant that we
can be i'm so pleased you're here that's
given me so much satisfaction i tell you
you've got no idea i promised you guys
i've kept my promise to stand by purnima
as a part of my respect
for what chefs ramsay has done to this
restaurant the kitchen looks immaculate
absolutely spotless
andrew any burgers with blotchies on
there no green burgers
this if i kill somebody
no green burgers what's going on in the
basement what about i'll show you the
basement there are no more bugs here
everybody was sent out for a week from
purnima i made them do a food protection
course oh my gosh
wow
holy mackerel
my god that's extraordinary
i cannot believe the difference
oh my god look i've got one in my
[ __ ] hands cockroaches
look at this
mohammed come over congratulations how
are you very good thank you good to see
you the best part of this thing is to
let chef ramjeans see the how we
transform oh he's very thrilled and he
is very excited which is a big thing for
us that's incredible well done i mean
well done it became such a big important
part of our lives just to make it
spotless clean oh my gosh when customers
come to the restaurant bikas loves to
invite them to look around in the
kitchen downstairs this is the main best
man to show them the changes we've made
are real this is completely transformed
wow
amazing
it was a very tough week when we're here
last year obviously martin didn't come
back no sure i know we have to move on
yeah how's business being
everywhere we're getting more and more
and more customers what's the restroom
turning a week now somewhere around 18
to 20. 18 20 000. yeah that's fantastic
it's a million dollars a year yeah
almost a million dollars a year
brilliant chef ramji definitely gives me
a second chance he motivated everybody
he just reignited the flame
like the lamb chops wow just a simple
marination of ginger and yogurt chef
ramsay's visit to purnima was extremely
important i am so happy i didn't expect
the transformation to be this good to be
honest the food it's absolutely
delicious for me the most important you
know connection was bringing you two
together i told chef ramsey that
and muhammad and andrew i promised them
that we will stand together and we may
make this restaurant a success
and it's such a good feeling being
reborn you see the whole place given
coming back to life purnima will always
have a very warm place in our hearts
next time we'll eat downstairs right
weird yeah
pony was a gift to us and i want to
respect that gift
good to see you chef it's a pleasure
it's so far too good looking to be a
chef you know that yeah
too clean can't because you know that
take care bye guys thank you
wow i mean absolutely incredible from
the biggest disaster to the biggest
transformation it's on track it's clean
it's delicious and now they have a
proper vision thank god for that
[Music]
last year when gordon arrived at this
italian eatery
company
he found a little bit of southern italy
in a new jersey suburb
one uh oh yes today i'm on my own and a
restaurant on the brink of disaster
mr ramsay there was joe the owner a
self-taught chef we don't have recipes
we don't use measuring cups or spoons
because i'm the best
he ran a carefree kitchen you while the
staff was goofing around
it's like a big romper room back there
joe was quickly going broke i owe my
purveyors about 80 000 right now in cold
hard cash joe's passion for big portions
was eating up his profits i can't see us
going on another year his wife was
distraught it takes a lot of courage and
his mom a nervous wreck i worry about
joe i worry about stress level i worry
about melissa i worry about the boys
the cash crunch took its toll these are
not working ovens and the customers paid
the price we've been here since seven
o'clock we need your specials now that
[ __ ] never went out but clearly
company's biggest problem was its food
garlic everywhere big big chunks of it
you wouldn't want to go back to the
office with that breath would you
holy mackerel looks like a vice's tongue
[Music]
oh dear my food i think is pure and
honest and good i think it was a mistake
that i did this
in the first dinner service gordon
noticed doggy bags on nearly every table
what's wrong with that uh nothing is
wrong with it
they're taking it away oh my god he knew
joe's huge portions made food costs
astronomical unbelievable and would
eventually force joe out of business
sit down sit down
i've never seen such humongous portions
why did you decide to go into business
if you haven't got a clue how to run a
business talk to me no
you're getting upset now yeah i'm
getting real upset i'm [ __ ] for that
hopefully i'll get through to you now
all right you know what why are we
making a [ __ ] public issue with this
now there's customers here this
customer's here i'd rather have this
conversation downstairs how about that
you're embarrassing me in front of my
customers
frustrated by joe's stubbornness the
next morning gordon decided to visit his
wife melissa to get a better insight
into joe hi melissa how are you
a lot of pressure on joe's shoulders um
how do you think he's doing he's very
positive and you know it's his dream and
i know he's giving it his all to you
know try and succeed but
the hardest thing for me is that people
like us put everything on the line for a
dream
and i just want to see him have the time
you know to succeed
this restaurant will
we would lose everything i mean i'll
lose my house this business can be
turned around
so you're gonna help
yes
determined to help joe and his family
gordon went right back to work
this menu is far too big for his own
good i don't understand what's going
through his mind to have this fridge
stocked with all these ingredients and
no customers to cook for look bag after
bag after bag this is where his 80 000
debt is
stupid absolutely crazy
i saw that [ __ ] walking in a
completely different light i went holy
[ __ ]
gordon's next step in turning compania
around was retraining the cooking staff
from prep to presentation i know it's
rustic but at least make sure that we've
got a little bit of pride in what we're
doing you can do better then gordon came
up with one menu item that would
separate compania from all the other
local restaurants why can't this
restaurant become famous for meatball i
go to my restaurant it's just like
meatballs that's what i want just give
me meatballs
armed with meatballs company's new
signature dish gordon and the staff hit
the streets to promote the restaurant
give these meatballs away and get the
reputation out there on the street yes
that's wonderful the best meatballs in
new jersey
now that the word was starting to spread
about the new company
lovely gordon introduced some decorative
changes how cool is that both outside
awesome oh it's unbelievable i was just
absolutely blown away
hey
and in
that place i just want to hang out you
guys have transformed my restaurant only
through the kitchen let's go
the kitchen got a state-of-the-art stove
and in a big push to cut costs gordon
introduced smaller plates for the
smaller portions
and a much more focused vibrant menu
on the night of the relaunch here we go
here we go come on gordon's new dishes
were welcomed by the customers
by the end of the evening the staff was
ecstatic more than 200 people were
served dinner and joe had his most
profitable night ever but there was one
important task gordon had to look after
before he left
the food looked great on there we're not
going back to stupid big
steering wheels that's what we're
serving look at them aren't they
horrible
[Music]
let's go
do one
say goodbye to them say goodbye
say goodbye
goodbye to the big plates hello prophets
one two three ghosts
[Music]
first day i met gordon i couldn't wait
until that guy said goodbye but once i
got beyond my ego being hurt and started
listening to what he had to say
he was like a true mentor to me hey
don't stop i won't
when gordon arrived in fairlawn new
jersey last year campana he found owner
joe in dire straits i owe my purveyors
about 80 000 but the staff was goofing
around relax when he confronted joe with
the truth if you haven't got a clue how
to run a business joel resented gordon
you getting upset now yeah i'm getting
real upset in the end gordon did make
big changes
and joe rose to the occasion on relaunch
night here we go here we go come on but
how is the home of new jersey's best
meatball doing today time to find out
last time i came to copenhagen i found
an owner that never clue how to run a
business my wife had seriously wanted to
give up and every member of staff for
far more interest and a good laugh as
opposed to serving a good dish can't
wait to find out what's happening
hello look at you nice to see you
how you doing it's very good to see
gordon today
business is doing a lot better since he
was here it's just busier and busier all
the time wow so busy
wow wow
ladies
how are you nice to see you though
i definitely hope gordon's really happy
for us and he's glad to see that we're
doing better and that i have a lot more
hope for the restaurant now and that
things are going easier restaurant
sounds great out there huh busy
you look great much better wow nice to
see you uh where's chef in the back
hey look at you hi everybody what's
going on yeah good to see you my man ah
the atmosphere in there as i walked in
was electrical that's like every day
fantastic since chef ramsay visited
campagna things have just turned around
on a dime completely the influx of
customers has nearly doubled and and
that's due to gordon before go to the
dining room have a quick peek in the
walk-in closet
i don't understand what's going through
his mind to have this fridge stocked
with all these ingredients and no
customers to cook for
take a gander enough for the next couple
of days maximum there's nowhere near the
amount of podcasts no i mean we were
stacked at the raptors before in in food
alone we're saving about five thousand
dollars a month that equates to about
sixty thousand dollars a year um we've
got so much of a financial cushion i
could finally pay my purveyors on time
it really helped me out so it's just
been nothing short of a small miracle i
almost feel guilty about how you know
how good it's been for me before gordon
was here we were pretty close to to the
edge financially it's been spectacular
but the hardest part for me was watching
my wife go through it because she didn't
sign up for it i did you look so much
more confident now because last time we
met and we had that chat it was pretty
hard on you yeah
the hardest thing for me is that people
like us put everything on the line
for a dream
how'd you feel now
better i mean you really gave him a
fighting chance you know i just think
gordon ramsay is so inspiring you know i
respect him for coming in here and being
honest and you know letting my husband
know what he needs to do are the bills
getting paid yeah they are good you know
they are it's been great it's so nice to
see you sounding and looking so
confident you know that and that kind of
support you give him is just the
foundation to the success of this place
so don't stop okay yeah good to see you
you too but it's important for me to see
my husband succeed this is what he wants
thank you so much really fast
hey you got a little meatballs nice to
see you my darling how many pogs and
meatballs have you served i sell tons of
meatballs everybody comes in looking for
these meatballs
a1 on a meatball they're delicious huh
good so soft yeah great that
is better than what we left it with i
mean we're sending trays out like you
know people want like 100 or 200 of them
they're asking if they can ship them
across the country you know
gordon's visit it was just thumbs up all
the way and man it was just infinitely
gratifying for me the last time we saw
this table you got pissed off with me
remember why are we making a [ __ ]
public issue with this now there's
customers here this customer's here i'd
rather have this conversation downstairs
you came in you know gave me like blow
after blow yeah and i took it pretty bad
you know ironically i think that that
was a really in retrospect a pretty
clever way of of um
just batting me down so much that i just
was able to really look at myself
objectively and to really see my flaws i
think nobody could have done that but a
guy like gordon smaller plays is it
working
yeah yeah i mean the customer doesn't
feel like they're getting any less you
know they're just not taking doggy bags
out that's delicious my god nice flavor
as extraordinary for gordon ramsay a
michelin three-star rated chef to come
in and give me the praise that he gave
today
a self-taught chef was just a phenomenal
compliment one
last thing very important gentleman i
think you should meet i'm mayor
weinstein how are you doing i'm joking
i'm asking a difference
gordon told me he had like one last
thing before he left you know
and i knew it was gonna be something big
thank you so much for coming thank you
and you're here because of the big
screen meatballs
give them a little presentation on
behalf of the borough a little
proclamation for you on the best
meatball not only in new jersey but
probably in the united states
you know joey's put everything into this
it's always been his dream thank you
very much certified it's been a long
road but good things are to come and
also today is your day in fairlawn today
is that's true on behalf of the mayor
and council
[Applause]
gordon coming in and making changes to
my restaurant actually translated into
big changes in my life at home no i feel
more confident as a father as a husband
as a restaurateur
gordon's had a huge impact on me
there's one more very important thing i
have to say those meatballs were [ __ ]
fantastic i've even got a doggy bag i've
never done this before
last year when gordon arrived in babylon
new york a small village on the south
shore of long island he found numerous
italian eateries but peters a family run
restaurant needed gordon's help more
than any other tina the owner was in
distress i want to cry or commit bloody
murder her brother peter the manager was
a bully
robert the chef was worn out when the
[ __ ] dishes are ready that's when
they're gonna come out the kitchen was
completely broken down this is my one
working outing
and peter's priorities were upside down
instead of buying a stove i bought a
suit you know he's a 250-pound
spoiled baby this italian eatery was on
the brink of bankruptcy i'm gonna kill
myself
gordon's arrival in babylon got off to a
slow start he said he's gonna pick me up
when peter kept him waiting nearly an
hour this can't be him
[Music]
peter how you doing gordon good to see
you nice car from the minute we met it
was like superman arrived
fdo
and from the minute gordon sat down he
knew this dysfunctional family was in
crisis i'd like to be told the truth
nothing but the truth
[Music]
it quickly became clear to gordon that
not only did this family have a
communication problem their kitchen had
some of the worst italian food he'd ever
tasted
that stone cold in the middle and that's
not fresh crab meat
that's not even lobster that's just like
baby food inside gunk
when gordon did finally step into the
kitchen [ __ ] he realized these chefs
were never given the proper tools what
doesn't work all these stove tops here
don't work this oven does not work peter
is a lot more proud of his car than is
his [ __ ] restaurant
then gordon inspected the walk-in and
was shocked by its condition
there's onions growing on top of onions
the whole thing leaking here
what the [ __ ] is that you can become
famous in the next 24 hours for [ __ ]
poison half of babylon does it just fall
under the chef's job this is your fridge
of your [ __ ] business and gordon
realized that most of the restaurants
problems pointed to one person it's like
blame everything on me stop acting like
your [ __ ] baby i'm not acting like a
baby
this is unbelievable
[Music]
gordon knew he had to have a heart to
heart with tina the owner about her
brother's irresponsible behavior does
peter play a part in the financial side
he'll take his paycheck but not come in
i come in and i'll they'll tell me oh
peter took 200
[ __ ]
it's like
i didn't even [ __ ] break even for the
day and he took money i get so
exasperated sometimes so stressed out
that i want to cry or commit bloody
murder
[Applause]
that night as the staff prepared for
dinner service tonight
is a critical crucial night an
unexpected bill collector arrived and
peter snapped
[Music]
come on
[Applause]
by the time customers arrived peter had
calmed down but he seemed to care more
about himself than them give me
pineapple juice with a lot of ice and a
splash of cranberry it's good for my
sugar
gordon knew if this restaurant was to
move forward he would have to confront
peter
i just think you've seen him day's work
for [ __ ] 20 years yeah i i've had my
own personal
problems we all have problems
let's
start working at the problem what's the
problem what's the problem
you that's where i'm starting
excuse me
you're the only [ __ ] here right now
is not pulling their weight and that's
not [ __ ] good enough think about what
are you going to put back into the
business tomorrow think about it
[Applause]
[Music]
the next day peter proved not just to
gordon but to the staff that he was
serious about his commitment to the
restaurant
we need our walk-in box fixed i'm gonna
be a team player here and whatever needs
to be done i'm gonna do i'm gonna jump
in i'm gonna ask people if they need
help with things
i even think peter will do his part i
really do think he's going to keep his
commitment
convinced that peter was determined to
change gordon revealed crucial
improvements to the restaurant
welcome to your new kitchen
oh my holy [ __ ] bro have a look have a
look have a look
the biggest change a brand new stove
every oven is working oh my god
a new double fridge as well
what a kitchen i think we were all
starting to boost steam here and give up
and he he brought us back to uh a sunny
day
your new kingdom
to prepare for the relaunch gordon went
to work on the state-of-the-art
equipment to create a new menu
there we go
i want to focus on family style dining
news of the opening spread through the
town and the restaurant was packed let's
set this up for 14 right now come on
come on come on the new menu was popular
with the customers
[Music]
the kitchen staff hit its stride the big
tables are all ordering family style and
peter worked hard to make the relaunch a
success
[Music]
we got a taste of how good
this ration can be absolutely and just
comparing to what i experienced the
first time i arrived here the difference
was night and day
the man
reinvented my restaurant if you cannot
make this work you're mad
take care
i really fell in love with him my first
son is going to be named after going
gordon ramsay pellegrino and god really
brought our family much closer together
[Applause]
now that a year has gone by it's time to
see how this family business is doing
today
[Music]
since last time gordon was here business
has been phenomenal
we took you know the fundamentals of
what gordon gave us and we built on it
and we followed what he did i mean how
could we not i mean you know he's he's
he's a proven winner right
hey
what's up team hey what are you doing
what's going on how are you good no just
going over saturday night's page oh yeah
looks busy i'd say that business
probably has to be up at least 30 40
percent we're at the top of our game
good evening peter
i am happy with the state of business
right now i think everything is i think
we're all really doing our best
saturday's sure what time i think we're
really working on our full potential and
if there's something that we see that
needs changing we we change it now how
you doing all right very good after
going left i realized it was time to
really make some changes here there were
fights every day and arguing and that's
where robert and john they just didn't
fit in anymore
when the [ __ ] dishes are ready that's
when they're gonna come out
my new head chef is fernando you guys
are doing a great job we're really busy
tonight everything's wonderful
in 20 years in business i've never met a
chef like fernando he's got a calming
effect it puts you at ease we're going
to start getting a little rush now we
have some big reservations about to come
in i think we're really happy everybody
here
they take care of me they treat me like
a family he trusts me and i trust him
morale does stem from the kitchen and
fernando has a lot to do with that you
know he's at his craziest moments he's
always at ease and that's transfers that
goes from the chefs to the waiters and
you know to us and back to the customers
it was good it was yours it was very
good we use the best of everything
everything is
top-notch from our produce to our meat
our fish and i'm just working hard and
doing it the right way and it's just you
know when gordon was here a year ago i
wasn't pulling my weight
let's
start working at the problem what's the
problem what's the problem
you that's where i'm starting
excuse me
he was right it would have been better
without me if you're not part of a
solution you're part of the problem and
i was i was part of the problem
my temper
got away from me in this business
and now i'm a much calmer person jordan
said something often in my head and at
the end of the day it really helped me i
do see the change in peter he'll always
be silly and
somewhat of a pain in the neck but um
i do see that he does care how's that
table a7 they are
they're all set they're good they're
ready to roll
i realize doing everything the right way
is much easier than doing it the wrong
way and that was stuff that gordon
taught me
would you like one as well frank yeah i
make a mean espresso when you're happy
in your business when you're happy in
the kitchen when everything is flowing
it just
transcends through the place
people see it it just trickles down and
the customers are really happy you know
what's good when you need more wine yeah
i know
gordon really pointed out how wonderful
this restaurant really is how lucky we
are to work together
i think gordon definitely saved us he
put everything in perspective and he
came uh just in time
too
okay and i thank you gordon i really do
it's symbol calls yes yeah i'm really
proud they were restaurants on the verge
of disaster
now they are on the road to success
gordon ramsay gave me that x factor that
aura that you can't pay for i'm sticking
to this plan and we're going to go
forward no matter what happens don't
stop please don't stop
it's like having the best of the best
tell you
you can do it a year has gone by and the
impact of chef ramsay's work is
undeniable chef ramsey gave a whole new
life to this restaurant thank you so
much really for everything he's
brilliant you know he really knows what
he's doing
but if they slip up
they just might get another visit from
chef gordon ramsay
you